all the tech platforms ban trump and d
platform parlor
the media bay for conservative heads and
house democrats push forward
toward a second impeachment i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so i just want to begin
today with something that i never do but
i'm going to do it now okay i really
don't do this because it's self-serving
and it seems silly
but i'm just going to say right now i
want you to go subscribe over at
dailywire.com
to this show it's what we do at
dailywire the reason i'm saying this is
because
we are quickly reaching crisis point in
terms
of the attempt to bar conservatives from
virtually every platform
that is what we are watching in real
time happen on the back
of the awful and evil incident at the
capitol last week the entire tech
infrastructure is now mobilizing
in order to take conservative outlets
off the air
in order to ensure that conservative
websites no longer appear
here's the thing they may not be doing
it right this second but they have now
set the predicate that they can do it
whenever they want
and what they are doing right now is
that the tech bros have declared war
on conservatives it's gonna be a slow
moving war they're gonna start with
people who are outliers they're going to
start with people who are considered
more radical
but they have basically decided that if
they at any point
have the opportunity to take you out
they will take you out so
i can't guarantee how long apple podcast
is going to be distributing things like
daily wire podcasts i can't guarantee
how long amazon web services is going to
allow
websites like daily wire to be up you
need to go
directly to the source you need to go to
dailywire.com right now and you need to
subscribe because it may be
over the course of the next couple years
it may be the only way you actually get
the content that you want
okay the way that facebook is moving the
way the twitter is moving the way that
all of these outlets are moving
all of these supposed platforms they are
now no longer really platforms they are
now publishers
basically based on what they are doing
the way that all of these outlets are
moving
they're moving more and more toward the
deplatforming dismissal
the creation of an echo chamber just for
the left that is what is happening
right now we are watching the purge okay
and it's not just on the tech level it
is also happening at the corporate level
it's already happened in hollywood it is
happening in the schools it is happening
nearly everywhere we are dividing
formally into two americas those
americas are not divided by state
they're not really divided by race those
americas are divided by politics
there will be a group of corporations
that only services the left
there will be a group of online
mechanisms that are only
allowed to actually platform the left
and
the right's gonna have to build its own
outside mechanisms
i've been warning about this for quite a
while it's it's amazing because the same
people right now who are calling for the
platforming the same people
who are calling for corporations not to
do business with people
who are conservative the same people who
are attempting to boot people from
platforms that were supposed to be
places for open discussion and debate
those same people complain that the
right lives in an echo chamber
well one of the reasons that the right
has increasingly lived in an echo
chamber is because the left has forced
everybody outside the overton window
the left continues to shrink the overton
window so that it encompasses only them
and only their friends everyone else
will be canceled everyone else will lose
access to even speak to other people and
what we are watching right now is one of
the most dangerous moments in modern
american history
not just because of what happened at the
capitol last week that was
extraordinarily dangerous and we are
finding out new details
showing how extraordinarily dangerous
that was for the congress people
for the vice president for everybody
inside for the police officers the
second
police officer committed suicide over
the weekend it was an extraordinarily
dangerous event
but it turns out that on the back of
extraordinarily dangerous events
extraordinarily terrible things can take
place and one of the things that is
taking place
right now is the division of america
into conservative
and liberal this could be a unifying
moment as i said last week because
everybody
of sound mind looks at what happened at
the capitol last week and is appalled
and thinks it's disgusting and horrible
instead what we are watching is the
exacerbation of an underlying
philosophical rift and not just that
what we are watching is the
formalization of that rift so that now
you're just not going to be able to
associate with anybody on the opposite
side of the aisle because the people on
the other side of the aisle will not
want to associate
with you in any way shape or form
okay axios is basically admitting that
this morning so axios
has a short piece by mike ellen and jim
vanderhey and here's what they write
republicans are losing power where power
matters most at the national level
in politics media technology and the
workplace
okay this is right and this happens to
be correct the right is being barred
from the halls of power in nearly
every area of american life from sports
to hollywood
from technology to your workplace right
you're getting the letters from your
employer saying
that if you posted in favor of trump
back in september or if you said i'm
voting for trump back in september
or if you post it against black lives
matter back in august well you know you
may lose your job
all your friends are going to look at
you as scans if you work in the tech
industry and you signify that you are in
favor of
sites like daily wire or daily caller or
anyone on the right
not being shadow banned or downplayed
you might find yourself on the firing
line
the the the political conflict that has
characterized the country
since inception i mean that's never
stopped has now boiled over into every
area of american life this is where it
affects americans
because let's you know who wins congress
who doesn't win congress
that has some impact on your life right
who wins the presidency who doesn't win
the presidency that has some impact on
your life in terms of regulations and
taxes and policy
what really has impact on your life is
how you're treated by your friends by
your neighbors
by your employers by the outlets that
you use
by the culture that surrounds you and
all of that is being twisted against you
right now if you are conservative and
axios
is pointing this time because the axios
happens to be correct about this
they say republicans often felt
mistreated when they had real power in
the form of the presidency in the senate
watch fox news or listen to ben shapiro
you will see and hear how this new
isolation will feed republican worries
and grievances in the months ahead
you see we're pouncing well maybe the
problem isn't that fox news and ben
shapiro are pouncing on this
maybe the problem is that people are
doing this in the first place
i have made my i've made my own show
very often
a place for discussion and debate we did
the sunday special every week
for what two years and the sunday
special was was designed
to allow me to talk to people on the
other side of the aisle you know how
many people refused to come on the show
you know how many people said i
literally will not sit in the same room
as you
and have a discussion with you because
that might legitimize your position
this happened on a routine basis you can
ask our producers who are asking people
across the aisle from us on the show
every single week
democrats according to axios will soon
control the white house senate and house
they already dominate most mainstream
newsrooms own big tech companies and
often band together inside corporations
to force politically motivated decisions
republicans will be left with mitch
mcconnell as party leader of a 50-50
senate
prime time and fox news in the wall
street journal editorial page most
importantly the right has the supreme
court which might prove to be the one
reliable counter balance and the
majority of power at the state level
but here's the key point conservatives
long ago lost so many key institutions
that define
national conversation including culture
media and higher education
now president trump has cost republicans
those tools of political power and
policy making the party will have to
rebuild
around new people and ideas well that's
a change from what axios originally
argued originally they said we are now
going to rethink things like free speech
freedom of association in this country
because that's what the left really
would like now that they have all
of the tools at their disposal they're
going to rethink free speech they're
going to rethink free association and
the way they're going to do that
is by proclaiming loudly and clearly
once and for all
that if you are on the right you are in
league with the people who stormed the
capital
that if you were a supporter of trump or
even if you didn't support trump if
you're just a religious conservative if
you're somebody who held your nose and
voted for trump because you looked at
the left and the left was getting
so insane that they were openly backing
black lives matters rioting and backing
critical race theory
and trying to ram down an extraordinary
level of intolerance
on right-wingers across the country and
on people who are middle of the road and
moderate liberals across the country
if you looked at that and you said you
know what i'm not into that now the rule
is that you were in favor of what
happened at the capitol last week
which is crazy and gross and the people
who are saying this sort of stuff
are are doing something deeply
politically malevolent
if you are lumping in with the hundreds
of people who should go to jail for a
very long time
who did what they did last week you're
lumping in with those people
these 75 million americans who voted for
trump and then
probably another 100 million americans
who disagree with the left on a wide
variety of issues
ranging from whether children should be
allowed to to change their sex
to whether americans should be divided
along the basis of race and then special
government benefits given to them
if you're lumping all those people
together and saying yeah you were those
people
then you that that's the problem you are
part of the problem
not the only problem but definitely the
biggest problem for the future of the
country
because let's be real about what
happened last week what happened last
week was an act of evil
and it was unsuccessful a republican
senate came back into session
and then voted for the certification of
the election mitch mcconnell
led the way vice president pence trump's
own vice president
presided over that it was a failure it
was a failure from beginning to end
that doesn't mean it wasn't evil it
doesn't mean it wasn't terrible it does
mean
that the system was resilient resilient
enough that within a couple of hours
everybody was regathering on the floor
of the same building that had been
invaded
and was voting in favor of the system
the danger to the system right now is
not the exogenous danger of rioters
taking over the capital the danger to
the system right now
is the complete lack of trust the
breakdown in basic cultures of rights
we talk on the show a lot about how
culture is upstream of politics
we talk on the show a lot about how a
culture matters more than the politics
that your culture shapes you the waters
in which you swim
right the stuff that you watch the
church you go to your neighbors that
really shapes
who you are as a person and then that is
manifest in politics
politics does not shape culture nearly
as much here's the thing when it comes
to your rights
when it comes to liberty a culture of
liberty a culture of freedom
is upstream of the politics of freedom
okay
there are a lot of people today who are
saying well you know what you're
complaining a lot but these are all
private corporations doing what they do
legally they're allowed to do what they
do that's true legally many of these
companies are allowed to do what they
they can fire you for being a
conservative they can
they're allowed to not to not allow you
to use your credit card
to pay for a subscription over a daily
wire they can
okay but a culture of right which means
a people
who prize the ability of people to do
things they don't agree with because
they believe in the underlying rights
that has to undergird any legal system
of rights because sooner or later and
usually sooner
a culture that opposes the rights of
others turns into a legal structure that
opposes the rights of others
it bleeds over incredibly quickly if you
think the first amendment is going to
protect you
if the entire culture has decided the
first amendment no longer matters
wrong you are and we can get to more of
this in a second and why this has become
such an issue
because over the weekend it really broke
out into the open first honest to god
like now is the best time ever to get a
vpn the social media companies have
decided they're going to monetize your
data while shutting down points of view
that you like
they've decided that they are going to
ban outlets that you like
well taking your data and then making
money off of you you should stop them
from doing this
they should not make money off of you
instead you should seize back control of
your own data with express
vpn did you know that your isp comcast
or verizon knows every single website
you visit
what's worse they can sell this
information to ad companies and tech
giants who will then use your data to
target you
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
your online activity cannot be seen
by anyone i use expressvpn on all my
devices and it works on everything
phones laptops routers so everyone who
shares your wi-fi can still be protected
even if they don't have expressvpn
the best part is using expressvpn is as
easy as closing the bathroom door you
just fire up the app you click one
button you are now
protected so if you're like me and you
believe your online activity is your
business secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
ben today use my exclusive link expr
essvpn.com get an extra three months
for free that's expressvpn.com like now
is the best time ever
to get an actual vpn like you need one
an expressvpn
is indeed the best one okay so let's
talk about what happened over the
weekend so the narrative
has now gone out the narrative is not
that a bunch of
kooks and evil people decided to storm
the capital last week but that every
republican was responsible
that this was completely foreseeable in
every respect at the moment trump rose
this was going to be the inevitable
outcome
and all of this is not true that's not
true okay
let me just take a quick example do you
really think that if this was the
foreseeable outcome
that like it was the most foreseeable
like the most likely thing was going to
be a bunch of q anon supporters
and and nutso's storming the capital and
taking pictures of a barbarian and a
helmet
if you thought that was the most likely
thing then why was ted cruz and josh
howley backing
the the silly illegality they were
backing why
why do you think they were doing that do
you think that they thought oh you know
what would be a great idea for me to
destroy my career so that people come in
like
to proclaim that this was foreseeable is
of course silly
okay here's how everybody thought the
last several months were going to go
exactly as they had gone meaning that
trump was going to and moan he was
going to go to a bunch of courts and he
was going to make a lot of arguments the
arguments were probably not going to be
convincing the courts were going to
reject them
state legislatures were going to reject
them the electoral college was going to
vote i was going to vote and then the
congress was willing to certify that
vote
and a lot of people would protest and a
lot of people would yell and trump would
probably lead a bunch of rallies
hey that was the most foreseeable
outcome why was that the most
foreseeable outcome because that's
always been the most foreseeable outcome
and in fact if policing at the capitol
had been proper that would have been the
total outcome
it turns out that policing the capital
was not proper and so it was not the
the total outcome i mean for goodness
sake how how
outlandish how out of the mainstream
were the people
who decided to storm the capital alex
jones was standing outside the capital
yelling at people to stop
when alex jones is the voice of reason
i think it's fair to say that the people
who stormed the capital are not
representative of the 75
million americans who voted for donald
trump but
the the revisionist history is that not
only was this inevitable every single
person who voted trump
every single person who didn't even vote
trump but talked up some of his policies
or who downplayed his tweets who said
that he says a lot of crap because he
does say a lot of crap who says that
trump is irresponsible in his rhetoric
that he heightens the tensions that he
makes the temperature warmer but
that he doesn't openly incite violence
anybody who said that sort of stuff they
all knew this was going to happen right
this is the line
this is the line so this led to the most
popular video of the weekend
arnold schwarzenegger and this does
signify where so many in the media and
sort of the mainstream left
wish the and arnold was never
a conservative right i mean when i was
in california he was governor of
california he governed basically like a
moderate democrat blew out the deficit
and all that
in any case here is arnold
schwarzenegger suggesting that what
happened last week
is like kristallnacht republicans are
like nazi fellow travelers
and then pledging allegiance to biden
forever this is one of the most popular
one of the most popular videos of the
weekend
about what happened last week i'm very
aware of kristallnacht or the night of
broken glass
it was a night of rampage against the
jews carried out in 1938
by the nazi equivalent of the proud boys
wednesday was the day of broken glass
right here in the united states
and john f kennedy wrote a book called
profiles in courage
a number of members of my own party
because of their own spinelessness
would never see their names in such a
book i guarantee you
they're complicit with those who carried
the flag of self-righteous insurrection
into the capital president-elect biden
we stand with you today
tomorrow and forever in defense of our
democracy
from those who would threaten it okay so
first of all
a few things here one all the best to
to president-elect biden in his new term
so long as he does things that that
obviously defend the rights
of the american people i wish him the
best when he does things that are good
for america
and when he and when he pursues policies
that i think are bad for america then we
should oppose him just as we would any
other president
any other president okay when it comes
to insurrectionists attempting to
prevent him from being
duly elected president of the united
states of course i i support him and
anybody else who opposes that
including mitch mcconnell including the
other republicans who oppose that
as far as the crystal knock comparison
it was a very long
talk here that that schwarzenegger did
where he talked about how his father and
and other men in austria would think
back to their time when they were
complicit with the nazis and then they
would
it was after world war two because he
was born a couple of years after world
war ii and they'd beat their wives and
they'd beat their children and they'd
get drunk
and the implication of course is that
there are millions and millions and
millions of americans who were complicit
in what happened on wednesday first of
all it was not crystal knocked you know
i know it wasn't crystal knocked because
krystal knocked for those who are
historically ignorant
happened in 1938 with the express
permission of the nazi government
okay not implied the expressed
permission and encouragement and
participation
of members of the nazi government okay
the the dictatorship
nazi government it wasn't there was
crystal knocked and then the legislature
came back into session and then said you
know what that was that you know
i can't believe those rogues right let's
let's move on with the business of
government okay first of all it was not
that it was a spawn a
government-sponsored
pogrom against jews 30 000 jews were
rounded up by the government
during crystal knocked and deported to
concentration camps seven thousand
jewish-owned businesses were burned down
267 synagogues were burned to the ground
hundreds of people were murdered at the
behest of the unified dictatorship nazi
government to compare what happened last
week to kristallnacht is a joke
okay it was not kristallnacht it was not
even close to kristallnacht
and yet the the comparison is meant of
course to inflame further
the comparison is meant to indict
anybody anybody
who once wore a maga hat or who voted
against
joe biden as complicit in the attack
last week
okay that was the goal because once you
do that you can do whatever you want
once you have labeled
half of the country nazis or nazi fellow
travelers
you can then do whatever you damn well
pleased to them right because not rights
shouldn't apply to those people because
if those people backed what we saw last
week well then we should be
de-platforming them
right we should be looking to to finish
their careers we should be
excising them from our social circles
right those are all things that we
should be doing so this is the goal
the goal is to to and as we'll see a
little bit later on
this is this is the overall move that
the left is making right now ban
everybody in media i don't like band
everybody on the other side of the aisle
i don't like ban every outlet i don't
like
and it's having it's meeting with a
fairly tremendous amount of success
so it started with trump but it's
certainly not going to end with trump
we'll get to that in a second because
trump has now been banned from nearly
every social media platform we'll get to
that
in just one moment first let us start
with the with the fact that it is a new
year and it's time for you to dress
right
it's time for you to look good and let
me tell you about cut clothing
they've taken a classic men's fashion
staple the plain tee they've refined it
combining premium quality with a
minimalist aesthetic
cuts shirts pillows hoodies crew
sweatshirts they're made for the man who
works hard plays hard never settles for
less all in the sport of business
they're built for performance in the
boardroom at the bar or the gym cuts
clothing keeps you sharp
wherever the game takes you take a plain
tee but make it tony stark the bleeding
edge of fabric technology meets the man
confidence enough to wear it
cuts clothing it's the perfect t-shirt
and then cuts has set out to create
uniquely engineered
clothing styles and fabrics consider the
new cuts hoodie
they developed the hyperloop french
terry fabric it's a texture that's a
textile that is temperature controlled
and ageless
you're never going to need to take it
off and you're not going to want to i
mean listen i own tons of cuts clothing
it is just fantastic i basically wear it
every single day i'm talking t-shirts
i'm talking polo shirts it's the most
comfortable stuff i own and
it happens to be cut perfectly it's like
taylor it's as though i went and got it
tailored
it is that good entrepreneurs mavericks
athletes podcasters
everybody loves cuts clothing they're
echoing gq it is the only shirt worth
wearing let's
kick off 2021 the right way starting
with your wardrobe get 15
off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com shapiro that is
cutsclothing.com
shapiro for 15 off the only shirt worth
wearing again i can testify to it it
really is the only short worth of
wearing it is that good
cutsclothing.com shapiro okay so here
are all the platforms that have so far
banned or restricted donald trump okay
and they've done so
on the basis of uh some pretty weak tea
so here are the comments that got trump
kicked off of twitter last week so he
was kicked off for
promoting the untruth promoting the lie
that he won the election and that it was
a huge victory for him
and that the and that there was a
possibility congress was going to
overturn it none of that was true
okay so they suspend him for 12 hours
when he comes back here's what he tweets
okay and it was this stuff over this
they decided they were going to ban him
here are his tweets they've now been
removed
because his accounts has been shut down
with its tens of millions of followers
quote
as i've been saying for a long time
twitter has gone further and further in
banning free speech and tonight
twitter employees have coordinated with
the democrats and the radical left in
removing my account from their platform
to silence me
and you the 75 million great patriots
who voted for me twitter may be a
private
company but without the government's
gift of section 230 they would not exist
for long
i predicted this would happen we've been
negotiating with various other sites
we'll have a big announcement soon while
we also look at the possibility of
building out our own platform in the
near future we will not be silenced
twitter is not about free speech they
are about promoting a radical left
platform where some of the most vicious
people in the world are allowed to speak
freely
stay tuned okay i have a question what
exactly is bannable about that
what violates twitter's policies serious
question
i have no idea what violates twitter's
policies there what they said is that
trump was now exacerbating the
possibility of violence with those
sweets
nope nope nothing in those tweets
exacerbates the possibility of violence
he literally says
there's a there's an alternative out
there presumably he's referring to
parlor which we'll get to in a minute
because this is the truly insane story
trump being banned from these various
sites
that's kind of wild considering he's the
sitting president of the united states
still
but it's what's happened to parlor over
the weekend that should scare the living
devil out of ever it should scare the
bejesus out of everybody i mean it's
insane it's insane
what is happening with parlor over the
weekend and so
here is a running list of all of the
outlets that have banned trump
okay reddit banned the subreddit group
donald trump a spokesperson confirmed to
axios
on friday twitch disabled trump's
channel citing the move as a necessary
step
to protect its community and prevent
twitch from being used to incite further
violence
shopify took down two online stores
affiliated with trump
for violating its policies on supporting
violence like selling maga hats i guess
is now supporting violence
twitter announced that they would
permanently ban trump's account
effective immediately
google pulled parlor which we'll get to
in just one second youtube
is accelerating its enforcement of
election misinformation and voter fraud
claims against trump
and other channels as well facebook
banned trump from posting on his
facebook accounts for at least the next
two weeks but mostly indefinitely like
forever probably
instagram banned trump from posting on
his facebook accounts for at least the
next two weeks but probably forever
snapchat disabled trump's snapchat
account because they said that the
account promotes and spreads hate and
incites violence
tick tock is from a chinese connected
company
is removing content violations and
redirecting hashtags like storm the
capital and patriot party to its
community guidelines
apple threatened to remove right-wing
friendly social media app parlor again
we'll get to parlor in just one second
because that's the bigger story
pinterest has been limiting hashtags and
stripe is no longer
no longer going to process payments for
trump's campaign right trump's campaign
continues to fundraise they can pay off
all of their debts
stripe and this again this one's a more
dangerous one stripe which is a payment
processing center has decided it is no
longer
going to process payments to trump's
campaign so
we've seen a bunch of social media
companies say they no longer
want to host donald trump's content and
do so in coordination well whenever
there's that sort of coordination it's
scary
okay by the way i said this about people
who i think are are significantly more
outlying than trump right i said this
when they ban they decided all at once
to be on milo they decided all it wants
to be in alex jones
i don't like any of those people as you
know from the show like at all at all at
all at all
but let's be frank about this twitter's
standards here are extraordinarily
extraordinarily inconsistent okay
twitter will allow kamala harris to
literally fundraise for people who are
in jail
for rioting twitter will allow people
to make death threats on a routine basis
against people who are
of right-wing of right-wing orientation
i know this because i was literally the
person targeted the most by anti-semitic
death threats on twitter in 2016. i
received
thousands and thousands and thousands of
them and twitter didn't shut down
all those accounts and twitter didn't
shut down accounts that were promoting
those accounts
so the standard that twitter is still
putting up and allowing to
to allowing to remain up tweets from the
iranian government calling for genocide
against jews in israel
tweets from the chinese government
touting its own sterile force
sterilization of women
in in zhang jiang okay like there are no
standards here
if there are standard and trump violated
it that's one thing there are no
standards is the reality the standards
just do not exist
and it's gonna it's going further than
that the pga of america
moved to ban the 2022 pga championship
from trump national golf club so the
idea now
is that all of the employees of trump
national who have nothing to do with
trump's political career
and all the people at trump national
like the groundskeepers
and the and the janitors and the people
who work
who work the club over there all those
people are going to lose out because
they've decided that you can't even do
business with any club that trump owns
because of what happened on wednesday
now
let me start from this perspective as i
said last week
you are to blame for incitement if you
tell people to go do violence
that's when you are to blame for
incitement but the standard does not
hold for the left
if you're bernie sanders and you say
over and over and over again that
republicans are literally killing your
grandmother because of their failure to
support medicare for all
and then one of your supporters goes and
attempts to murder dozens of republican
congress people and nearly shoots one to
death in steve scalise
you know who's not responsible for that
bernie sanders he's responsible for
increasing the temperature he's not
responsible for the
for the insane person who decided to
shoot people based on that
let's say that you are the president of
the united states and you say over and
over and over and over again
that the police in the united states are
systemically racist that they are
targeting
black people for destruction and then
let us say that
a supporter of black lives matter goes
and murders six police officers in
dallas you know he's not responsible for
that barack obama he didn't want people
to do that
he didn't call for people to do that and
yet the idea here
is that trump is responsible like
directly responsible so much so
that no one can ever do business with
any business associated with him he
should be banned
from all of his accounts not on the
basis of violating policy but on the
vague
basis that he is a threat to the public
peace here is why i am so skeptical
of these claims about threats to the
public peace they are wildly
inconsistent
like insanely inconsistent it turns out
the only people who are quote-unquote
threats to public peace
are precisely the people that the left
doesn't like anyway
so let me take what i think is perhaps
the best example of this
ever so keith boykin is a cnn
commentator
so he uh he tweeted out over the weekend
quote
imagine this scenario reverend al
sharpton holds a rally and tells his
supporters to take back their country
with strength and combat
then five people die after black lives
matter activists stormed the u.s capitol
how would fox news and congressional
republicans respond
this is such an unbelievably great
example of how the left just doesn't
have
it's not that the left has has a double
standard it's that the left doesn't have
a standard the standard is
that if you are a conservative you are
bad and we will hold you accountable for
anybody
anything anybody does he actually used
reverend l sharpton in an example of
what would people do
if somebody incited a riot okay if
you're talking about borderline
incitement of rioting
al sharpton did that twice two times
he literally did it in crown heights in
1991 when he said at a funeral for a
blackhead
who was who was hit by a car driven by a
hasidic jew
he said if they want to get it on let
them pin on my pin back their yamaha and
come on over to my house
okay a riot in crown heights ensued
an orthodox uncle rosenbaum was killed
then a few years later
there was a store called freddy's
fashion mart it was not in fact
owned by jews it was in fact run it was
kind of sub-leased to a jew in any case
he suggested that diamond merchants had
invaded the neighborhood okay and
this resulted in one of the people who
was at one of his rallies going and
burning freddy's fashion mart ending in
the death
of at least one person what so what
happened to al sharpton good question
well let's see he ran for president in
2004 on the democratic side of the aisle
he was visited by every major democratic
candidate this year
in order to receive their blessing he
has a show on msnbc and he gets to
comment on stuff like this
so keith boykin it seems like there is
no standard when it comes to people on
the left bernie sanders
can use rhetoric so incendiary that a
person goes and tries to murder congress
people
and that results in him nearly winning
the democratic presidential nomination
al sharpton is the most well respected
quote unquote civil rights leader he's a
scam artist and a grifter
he's one of the most respected civil
rights leaders on the left
after having participated in rhetoric so
incendiary that two riots ensued
and you're telling me that there's
there's a double standard here i think
that you've got this a little bit wrong
and none of this is to argue that
trump's rhetoric has been anything
remotely approaching good here
i've said since the very beginning i
said literally since election night when
he declared that he had won the election
i said that he's irresponsible and wrong
you cannot do that
and then i said there's no evidence that
the evidence is not sufficient to show
that the election was stolen i said that
over and over and over again and then i
said there's no legal basis for
returning the election
i said all of those things over and over
but that does not mean that he
quote unquote incited to the point where
he
you know forced these people or wanted
these people to invade the capital and
certainly it doesn't mean
that all of the people who are who voted
for trump the 75 million americans voted
for trump are responsible for that and
yet that is exactly the pitch
that's the pitch the pitch is that you
are responsible all of you are
responsible
right see by declaring that violence is
just around the bend and that anything
any conservative says is going to result
in violence and all of it is foreseeable
what the lefties really attempting to do
is they are attempting to implement the
standards they've been implemented in
germany for a long time
since world war ii germany has
implemented a standard it's called
stripe democracy the basic standard is
that if they think
that you are saying things that
undermine democracy it is more of a
threat
to democracy than shutting down your
speech and thus your speech can be shut
down
so what the left is attempting to do is
claim that all conservatism
inevitably ends in violence and
therefore you should be shut up
and therefore you should be shut up and
what this is going to result in is
massive banning it's going to result in
massive deplatforming
it's gonna result in the complete
siloing of political perspectives in the
united states it is well on its way
this is why i say go subscribe right now
to daily wire before they make it
unavailable to you
do it right now okay we'll we'll talk in
just a second about
how you can tell this is coming first
let us talk about the fact that um you
might need coffee right now i need
lots and lots of coffee i found myself
drinking coffee like an insane person
over the last
couple of weeks simply to keep up with
what is going on well that is why you
need the most liberating coffee known
i'm talking about black rifle coffee
black rifle coffee company it's a
veteran-owned coffee company serving
premium coffee
to people who love the country veteran
ceo founder evan hafer spent over seven
years on the ground overseas with u.s
special forces
and as a cia contractor evan even
modified his gun trucks during the
invasion of rock's grind coffee anywhere
black rifle coffee company it's
continually committed to supporting
veteran
law enforcement and first responder
causes with the companies buy a bag give
a bag campaign
they make sure to give the gift of
america's coffee to those that serve
around the globe
in 2020 they donated over six million
cups of coffee brcc offers a variety of
roast profiles all sourced from around
the world through rigorous processes
roasted in the united states at brcc
facilities in tennessee and utah and the
best way
to enjoy black rifle coffee through the
coffee club free subscription your
chosen coffee is roasted packaged
shipped free to your door on your
schedule in addition to the convenience
you'll receive at special discounted
pricing and gain access to exclusive
products get the freshest coffee in
america without leaving your couch head
on over
to blackriflecoffee.com appear i know
the dudes who run it they are fantastic
get 20
off your purchase and your first coffee
club order that is black
rifle coffee dot com slash apparel
coffee is fantastic
black rifle coffee dot com slash should
be here to get 20
off your purchase and your first coffee
club order
okay so how do we know where this is
going we know this is going because the
left isn't being shy about it
so over the weekend for example there
was a uh
a woman named leia torres who is a a
well-followed
dr md online she tweeted out about
lila rose our friend lila rose from live
action who's a pro-life advocate
she tweeted out january 7th abortion is
violence okay it is
it turns out that when you um kill a
baby in the womb that is not an act of
peace
exactly and is an act of violence
against another living human being it's
a typical pro-life
position leia torrez tweeted out this is
violent rhetoric it is objectively false
and meant to incite others to commit
crimes against clinics patients and
healthcare providers
this is what domestic terrorism looks
like
okay this is this is how it's going to
go it's turtles all the way down
the point here from the left is going to
be over and over and over again that if
you are right-wing
you are inciting violence if you're a
conservative you're inciting violence
and you knew that trump was inciting
violence and so if you voted for him
you're responsible too
this is the unpersoning of tens of
millions of americans that we are about
to watch
john brennan who committed literal
crimes i mean john brennan
had his cia spying on the legislature
and then he lied to the american people
about it
which is in fact a threat to the
constitutional order he tweeted out
anyone now seeking national redemption
by claiming to no longer support trump
must acknowledge how wrong it was to
ignore and enable his corrupt dishonest
and divisive agenda
total denunciation of a despot's legacy
is necessary to eradicate
any remaining malignancy so in other
words if you supported the abraham
accords or if you supported the tax cuts
or if you just liked his judicial picks
or if you thought that sometimes when he
was fighting back in the culture wars
that was absolutely justified
you are part of the problem right you
cannot be redeemed you're irredeemable
you're irredeemable meanwhile you got
nicole hannah jones nicole hannah jones
is of course the progenitor of the 1619
project a pack of lies about the united
states of america
you have to understand how all of that
ties in here as james lindsay has
pointed out on twitter the entire
argument of the 1619 project is that
america is a white supremacist project
and therefore that project came to its
culmination last week in the capitol
building
and the only way to cure america is to
wipe clean everybody
right so she tweeted out she's a damned
liar
and she's a prevaricator a pulitzer
prize-winning garbage
pseudo-historian she tweeted out the
reckoning needs to come to the media too
uh there it is and what i love most is
our guardians of first amendment
freedoms the people who say it's really
bad when trump called the press the
enemy of the people
saying that it looks like some of the
members of the press are enemies of the
people
right i mean that's what it sounds like
right there the reckoning imagine if
trump had tweeted out the reckoning
needs to come to the media too
imagine just change the picture in the
name the reckoning needs to come to the
media too
would that count as incitement against
the media would that count as an attack
on fundamental elements of our republic
but according to nicole hannah jones no
no the reckoning needs to come for
anyone i disagree with
well here's one of my personal favorites
sarah zhang so sarah zhang is a
columnist a tech columnist for the new
york times
so sarah zhang a few years ago you'll
recall this because we podcasted about
it
sarah zhang people dug up some of her
old tweets they were super racist
they're all about how white people were
super bad and terrible white men were
awful they're really really bad and
there's a lot of talk online about
whether
she'd just been hired by the new york
times she should be able to keep her job
at the new york times
some of us argued that canceled culture
should not prevail here the new york
times knew exactly what she was
and they should hire her they should
continue to hire her let them be as
openly political and awful as they want
to be
right some of us defended her rights
some of us did
but not sarah zhang she learned nothing
she's going to go after everybody else
so who should be banned she says i
wonder when twitter is going to ban andy
no
andy no of course is the on-the-ground
journalist who's been documenting the
predations
of antifa and so she says it's time to
ban and
right now is the time we get to go after
all our enemies since this is so
exciting right i mean if you're on the
left
now is a time when yeah something really
bad happened last week and that was
terrible but
the good news is now is a perfect time
to de-platform and destroy
anybody who disagrees with us and use
every tool at our disposal from tech
to the media to corporations to really
just you know wipe the slate clean
let's just do this thing meanwhile over
in congress
meanwhile over in in congress cory cory
bush who is a blm activist joined by
ayanna presley they are now suggesting
that the 14th amendment
which says that you cannot be a senator
or republican a senator or
representative
rather in congress or elector of the
president or vice president
if you joined in an insurrection a
rebellion right it was written
right after the civil war right so meant
to refer to people who had engaged
in the actual confederacy cory bush said
yes it's the 14th amendment
and it's why i'm introducing a
resolution to investigate and expel
the members who attempted to overturn
the presidential election and incited a
white supremacist coup
attempt if you agree call your
representative and ask them to
co-sponsor it
now is a perfect time to throw any
elected representative elected
representatives
out of congress on the basis that they
were complicit in an insurrection
all of them so i can disagree with josh
haley i can disagree with ted cruz i can
say i thought that their policy was
cynical
i thought what they were doing was not
constitutional i thought that they were
doing was not legal
that is not that is not an actual coup
attempt okay that is not an insurrection
nor are they guilty for people rushing
into the room those are
those are individuals with agency do you
think that josh halley when he when he
walked outside and he shook his fist at
the protesters
in support do you think that he thought
five seconds later they're gonna be
invading the capitol building
do you think he did really in your heart
of hearts do you think that josh haley
thought that
because that would make him the
stupidest person on planet earth right
to tie
the hitch's wagon to that nonsense to
that evil
okay but that is that is the pitch right
so now everyone in congress who
who you don't like and does something
that's bad those people need to be
thrown out by the way if we if we
consider
that the basic premise of so much of the
left's
ideology is predicated on overthrowing
basic american rights i guess if we
broadly construe that
then maybe the 14th amendment should
apply there too or maybe it shouldn't
maybe this is still a free country where
people get to say things
okay but apparently not because this
brings us to the actual biggest story of
the day the actual biggest story of the
day is what the tech companies just said
to parlor
that is the most threatening it is the
most scary it's egregious it's egregious
capital e we'll get to that in one
second first let's talk about now being
the perfect time to take your business
to the next level it's time to staff up
your company the way that it needs to be
with the help of god this year the
economy is going to boom
people are going to get back to normal
the vaccine will kick in and then you're
going to need employees
and if you're an employee you need a
great employer and this is where a zip
recruiter comes in what is the fastest
easiest way to connect employers and
employees
zip recruiter right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire ziprecruiter will do the work
for you when you post your job
zip recruiter sends it out to over 100
top job sites with one click
then their powerful matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply so
you get qualified candidates fast it's
no wonder that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within
the very first day see for yourself
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire that is
zip recruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-re we've been using zip
recorder here for a very long time
you may have noticed some turnover on
our credits thanks zip recruiter are you
ready to build your team for 2021 head
on over to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire ziprecruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire go check them out
right now okay so this brings us to the
biggest
story of the day we'll get to it in one
second okay this is the the
attempt to de-platform parlor to
literally take them offline
not just by some of these supposed free
speech platforms but by
actual data providers okay this should
scare the living if you're a free speech
person
right left center they should scare the
living hell out of you it should because
it can happen
to anyone based on what the woke
standards of the day are or the leftist
standards of the day
it's really frightening we'll get to
that in a second first
look we are gonna fight this culture war
we're gonna we're gonna have to fight it
on every single front i started the show
today by talking about how the right
had basically abandoned the
institutional structures
in favor of individualism which is good
but they abandoned the institutions one
of those institutions
is the cultural institutions places like
hollywood well we need to get back
into the business of providing people
content on every front
that convinces them that conservatives
are not only not bad but are quite good
on friday january 15th my birthday
daily wire is releasing its first
feature film run hide fight exclusively
to daily wire members run hide fight is
not particularly political it is intense
it does have a powerful message
the movie follows a high school besieged
by a quartet of school shooters
one young girl 17 year old zoe hall uses
her wits and survival skills to fight
back
here is the trailer
[Music]
in between breath take the shot
you're doing really good out there kid
size of that deer we're going to be
eating venison all summer
well the days work i think we need to
see somebody again by we
mean me no i mean us hey that look in
your eye
guys in my evening hate that look maybe
there's a brochure you can hand me so i
can go
[Music]
is that chris jellic over there is he
doing something completely weird
senior prank day but we'll see all kinds
of dumb stuff today swim captain we'll
have thai food delivered to class and
becky vaughn will set up our homemade
slip and slide this is high school
nothing that happens to your matters in
the real world
okay we are in charge now so please pull
out whichever app you use to do live
streaming video get them up and running
and point it at me now
get down on the ground any more friends
back there
i'm calling 911
you must be close
[Music]
you should be ashamed
very disturbing news out of vernon
central high school
zoe
[Music]
in between breath take a shot
go is it safe to say that this might be
our guardian angel
do you want more people to die that's
the last thing i want i'm gonna kill one
person in this room every five minutes
you don't show your face
isn't it ironic that after all your hard
work
people aren't gonna remember you
no they're gonna remember me
to mark the release of run hide fight we
will be doing a live stream premiere the
night before
thursday january 14th special episode of
backstage features jeremy boring and me
and special guest come join us as we put
the culture
on our own terms now not only can you
subscribe and help us out as we join
into the
cultural fight but also you can come
work here we have a bunch of open
positions right now you can check out
those opposite open positions
at dailywire.com right now and see if
maybe you qualify
to join us you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
okay so the big story of the day is of
course that parlor has now been banned
by apple google and amazon web services
which basically takes them offline so
this is an astonishing thing
it's an astonishing thing it should
scare the living hell out of all of you
it should it should scare you okay
because not only were they booted from
facebook
and booted from twitter they were also
booted
from the the apple store for example so
you couldn't download
the app they were they were booted from
google so
like all their platforms and then worst
of all
amazon shut parlor down from its cloud
hosting service that's amazon web
services right which is basically the
servers they took away all their servers
and they said you can't use our servers
anymore so it's one thing to remove it
from your app store it's another thing
to say
you literally cannot exist online
because we are taking your servers away
from you right
you no longer get to have your servers
now imagine
just for a second if in the middle of
the black lives matter riots and they
were
riots they happened in hundreds of
places around the country imagine
if in the middle of the black lives
matter riots facebook
had been kicked off of its web hosting
services it had been kicked off of the
app store by apple
because people were using facebook to
organize protests that devolved into
riot
and people were probably making comments
on there that were really bad let's say
that they were doing that which we know
they were
or instagram where people were
coordinating their activity or let's say
the twitter which has been used for more
violent threats against me personally
than any other app
let's say that they're web serving that
amazon web servers just decided you know
what
nope no more twitter the reaction would
be wow that sounds
really really scary and fascist in fact
to de-platform
entire applications because people were
misusing the application
cuts directly against the culture of
free speech not the legal of free speech
the culture of free speech
again these companies have a right to do
what they are doing but as we'll
we will talk about in a second when
you're talking about monopolistic
collusion which is really what this
looks like
i am as anti-regulation as any person as
any person in america
but you got to be worried about this and
you should be worried about this because
again
to be kicked off your server like here
was the idea the idea was okay you
didn't like twitter go build an
alternative
right i said it i said it many times i
said i don't want twitter regulated i
want an alternative
so parlor came up now i'm not going to
vouch for powerless policies
i don't know parlor's policies but i do
know that what you cannot do is force
people off a platform like twitter
you know you blew people off or you
alienate people so they build an
alternative
and then you remove the alternative
right everybody should go elsewhere
they said and they say okay so build
your own twitter like okay so build our
own twitter they go build parlor
and then like well you know what amazon
web services doesn't have to support you
so you need to go build your own server
farm
and after that you know what you need to
do you need to go build your own fiber
optic infrastructure
maybe what you need to do and if you
can't find a bank to lend you maybe you
need to build your own banks
well maybe you do maybe that's where all
of this is going
but imagine for just a second if this
had happened around blm and not around a
conservative oriented platform
imagine for a second that again facebook
had been deplatformed because people
were using facebook in order to
coordinate activity
in the middle of a pandemic by the way
that was going to violate not only law
but was also going to violate basic
precepts of human decency in the form of
riots
and so people have been like you know
what facebook's done we've just taken it
down people would be like wow that's
insane
but today the media are celebrating this
like openly openly celebrating this the
tech bros
are taking a bad moment a really bad
moment for the country they are making
it significantly worse
because there is no consistent rule they
are applying here if we are talking
about apps that allow bad stuff to
happen on them twitter is like top of
the list
okay and and here is the thing that's
amazing so people talk a lot about
section 230.
i've said because legally this is
correct section 230 doesn't make a
distinction between platforms and
publishers what section 230 does
is it says you are not responsible for
open source posting on your website even
if you do some moderation of the open
source posting
right so if there's a comment sections
on daily wire daily wire is a
publication
we are responsible for what our editors
and writers put up but
if there's a comment section and then we
moderate it to get rid of for example
violent threats
then we still will not be held
responsible for the violent threat
for anything that happens in the
comments section now section 230 to
understand what it was about
originally it was well understood under
basic
precepts of american law that you don't
hold platforms accountable for how
people use the platforms
so for example everybody uses phones for
years
most crime was committed not online but
it was committed via phone right because
there was no internet so if you wanted
to commit a crime you'd pick up the
phone you'd use att you'd call your
criminal buddy and you'd go rob a bank
was att responsible for that phone call
and the answer always was no
they're a platform they're not actively
encouraging you to commit that phone
call
right so att was a platform okay and
then
when it came to the internet that was
also the idea was these open source
platforms were not responsible for any
activity that happened that was illegal
on the uh it wasn't assumed to redound
to the liability of the company that
allowed the posting right if you had an
open source
and somebody posted a bad comment on
youtube or posted a bad comment on
twitter or posted a bad comment in the
daily wire comments section
none of those places were responsible
for the bad comments that were posted it
was just the person who was responsible
for the bad comments that were posted
then some people said you know what
we need a better internet and there are
some places that actually do want to do
some comment moderation
so they want to get rid of for example
pornography in their comment section
they want to get rid of spam in their
comments section
does this make them liable because they
are now curating
and the answer section 230 said was no
it doesn't make them liable they're
allowed to do some of the curation to
make the comment sections better
okay now what has happened so the
baseline assumption there was that open
threads were not going to lead to
liability
right the moderation could lead to
liability so we removed the liability
from moderation
that's what section 230 was now we have
reversed it so now the idea is if you do
not moderate
you are liable so the only people who
are not liable in the cultural sphere
are the people who do not moderate so in
other words
only if you follow the the standards
these screening standards the the
fact-checking standards
or the informational standards of
twitter
or facebook or apple or amazon only if
you do that will you be allowed a
platform in the private sector
only if you do that will you be allowed
this okay that's an insane reversal of
the intent
of section 230 obviously which again was
meant to protect
a lot of these corporations from from
liability because they were moderating
not in spite of their
not not because we wanted more
moderation but because we just wanted to
make sure that people who were
moderating weren't getting punished
extra
okay but now parlor has been dropped not
just by not just by
the apple store but also by everyone
right by apple
by amazon web services now again
i'm all in favor of the free market but
you have to wonder about monopoly
practices here
when the technological instruments that
are necessary for free speech are
located basically in three companies
okay because in order for you to be
online in order for you to even host a
website
you basically are doing it through one
of three companies amazon
microsoft which is azure or google right
those are the three companies and it
really is mostly amazon amazon controls
according to the uh according to the
firm stanford they control about 50
percent of all public cloud
infrastructure
microsoft controls about 16 percent
scenario up to 66 percent
google controls about four percent and
they're a vast bedding of like tiny tiny
little firms that have a little bit
of public cloud infrastructure but not
nearly of the size and scope necessary
to actually allow pages to load fast
latency comes out and it's a real
problem
okay so you have these three companies
and not only are these three companies
controlling all of the
infrastructure which again that's okay
they are colluding in what they wish to
ban they're they're colluding in their
standards
even the consumer-based theory of
anti-monopoly which is one i subscribe
to right if it's not bad for consumers i
don't really care about monopoly
if the consumer-based theory is is true
it is very bad for consumers when all of
the companies are agreeing on the same
exact standard for what they will
platform and what they will not platform
because there are no alternatives
available
you know everybody on the right is
correctly concerned that this ain't
gonna stop at parlor
they're saying a parlor didn't keep to
our moderating our moderating standards
let me tell you the moderating standards
and twitter are garbage they're pure
garbage
the moderating standards at facebook are
a little better not super a lot
as by the way the left has been saying
but everybody is worried where this is
going to go and they should be they're
worried that they're gonna take down
podcasts like this one from the apple
store
they're worried they're gonna take down
the daily wire app saying that it's
quote unquote misinformation on the
basis of bulk fact checkers uh
these these fact check sites that are
that are left-wing oriented
everybody is worried about that and they
should be worried about that because
that is where this is going
that is where this is going it's going
to get worse and worse and it's not
going to stop they are going to d
platform everyone
here was parlor's ceo yesterday saying
we were dropped by every single vendor
they made an attempt to not only kill
the apps
but to actually destroy the entire
company and it's not just these three
companies
every vendor from um
from text message services the email
providers to
our lawyers all ditched us too on the
same day
and and then they're trying to uh
falsely claim
that we were somehow responsible for the
events that occurred on the sixth
okay and this is what's going to happen
to company after company because so long
as the left can connect you to violence
so long as the left can even make the
argument
the left's goal is going to be
deplatform you and ruin you personally
ruin your company
get you fired destroy you in your social
life
this is the tsunami the tsunami is here
okay so as i said at the beginning
go subscribe to your favorite sites
because you don't know when they're
going to be taken down
go help out the people who you want
information from because the tsunami is
coming and it is coming on fast it's
already coming for parlor it is not
gonna stop
at parlor now the question becomes what
replaces that
right what replaces that okay so here's
here's what replaces that what replaces
that
is the monopoly media where it places
that is the re-establishment of the
monopoly the monopoly media
so that's been the whole goal here right
why do you think there's so many members
of the new york times have been stumping
for literally years the kara swishers
and kevin ruses of the world of the new
york times
stumping for years on end the jugular
gumball gums
all these people saying every outlet
that is not left wing should basically
be shut down deplatformed
marginalized all of these should be shut
down why
so they can re-establish control of all
methods of informational distribution
and then they can just control you see
we can have a happier america because we
all think the same right
we all think the same because we're
getting our information from the same
five sources
all of which are now the trusted news
sources over at facebook right facebook
has this
this quality control measure that they
were using the last days of the election
which naturally suggested that the
quality outlets were ones like cnn
and the non-quality outlets were ones
like you know the new york post because
they printed all that hunter biden stuff
and i trust our media i do i mean i
think that they are trustworthy people
and that they have really strong
standards when it comes to
misinformation and disinformation
which is why pbs hosted dan rather
the former news anchor from cbs who
literally presented a falsified document
about george w bush going awol in 2004
as their commentator on why we need
better information from our media i mean
this is beyond parody it's just beyond
party here's pbs newshour again
pbs is a public broadcasting system
right it is publicly sponsored taxpayer
sponsored
monopoly media here they are talking uh
talking with dan rather
an overt an overt journalistic liar
about the standards and media that need
to adhere
everything is on the table for this
country and we need to recognize that
that we can have a great future a future
bigger and better than anything our
fathers and mothers ever dreamed of
but we have to move because we're we're
cheating on the
on the imbalance here if you will of
just what you describe the world in
which
truth is rarely pure never
easy to come by and increasingly
difficult to sort
out oh well let's yeah him how about
brian williams
back on msnbc like these are the these
are the journalistic standard bearers
right guys
these are the people we should trust we
shouldn't have a plethora of voices we
should shut down any other voices and we
should blame them for stuff they didn't
do
that's what we should do and then we can
have a unified front
on what is true and what is not sure
it's manufactured
sure the only way that that unified
front is created is by excising
anyone who descends but then we'll at
least have a unified front and we can
get into real journalistic issues like
for example
why kamala harris was on the cover of
vogue magazine in one pose as opposed to
another pose
this was the the giant controversy over
the weekend in media land
we'll go back to the worlds in which
barack obama never had a scandal except
for his tan suit
because after all everyone will think
the same it'll be great over the weekend
if you missed this there's a giant
controversy on twitter
over kamal harris being on the cover of
vogue magazine why was it a bad cover of
kamala harris on the cover of augment no
of course not it was a
picture of her in a pant suit and
converse sneakers that she likes to wear
on the campaign trail
saying madam vice president kamala
harris and the new america
by the people for the people of the
united states of fashion
okay this was the bad picture because
she's standing in front of like a pink
curtain that she is standing on
that's the bad picture and how dare they
how dare they disrespect her that way by
putting her there wearing what she wears
on the campaign trail
by the way quick note how many covers of
vogue magazine was melania trump an
actual fashion model featured on
but here's kamala harris a style icon in
that she wears the same exact thing
that every person wears to the office
who is a female but also converse
sneakers
so this became a massive controversy
because oh my gosh here is the vogue
cover that kamala harris's team thought
would be released wow in that one she's
in like
a powder blue pantsuit as opposed to the
other one where she's in like
a black pantsuit oh my god well i mean
now the media are really doing their
jobs yes charlie says i'm told this
cover on the left will be the digital
cover but the much maligned cover on the
right has already gone to print and will
be the cover available for sale
and sent to subscribers wow armenia
really like
it's a time of crisis in the country but
our media really focusing in on you know
the huge issues
meanwhile promulgating narratives that
again are extraordinarily biased so
jeffrey goldberg who is
an obama administration stenographer
literally ben rhodes suggested that
jeffrey goldberg was used as a
mouthpiece for the obama administration
over and over and over and over
including in propagandizing for the iran
deal so now jeffrey goldberg
who is such a free speech advocate that
he fired kevin williamson from the
atlantic for the crime of being kevin
williamson
after hiring kevin williamson because he
knew who kevin williamson was
gutless pathetic dweeb over here jeffrey
goldberg
here's jeffrey goldberg i say that as a
fellow dweeb okay so if i'm gonna weave
and i look down on other dweebs
they're super dweebs here's jeffrey
goldberg suggesting you know
that the fair perspective the fair
perspective is that trump incited a mob
to sack the capital is that the fair
perspective though or is that you know
like a little biased that he incited a
mob to sack the capital
here is jeffrey goldberg on cnn you know
again these are your news people and
once you establish monopoly
news you have the control over the over
the auspices of information
when you're describing what happened
this week it probably should be
described simply as
the president of the united states
incited a mob to go
sack the capital and lynch the vice
president his vice president
i mean that is that is a fair way of
describing
what would uh what what happened or what
could have happened
uh had the mob broken through and got to
the vice president or the speaker of the
house or other members of congress
they were they were they were looking
for violence
yes they were looking for violence but
the fair way to describe it is the
president incited the mob to sack the
capital and hang the vice president
is that really is that the fair way to
describe that as before
i've held the exact same standard for
bernie sanders as i've held for barack
obama as i hope for donald trump when it
comes to the standard of incitement but
the left has no such standard
the the standard just doesn't apply to
folks on the left but it definitely
applies to people on the right let me
just remind everybody
that donald trump can do a lot of bad
things he can raise the temperature he
can tell lies he can misinform people he
can make them believe things that are
not true
or at least say things that are not true
and then they believe them he can do it
over and over and over again
but it is worth noting that this was an
actual line in the speech
that he gave right before the capital
was stormed
okay here is a line from trump's speech
and this is the same line where he said
we're gonna march over to the capitol
right now
here was trump is clip 16 talking about
what was going to happen next
we have come to demand that congress
do the right thing and only count the
electors who have been lawfully
slated lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
oh did you hear that word peacefully in
there peacefully and patriotically now
does that mean that the rest of the
speech was not inflammatory no
it was inflammatory but you do have to
know if you're a new per
if you're a news person you might want
to note somewhere in there that the
president did say that people were going
to patriotic and peacefully
make their voices heard and by the way
that's probably what trump thought was
going to happen because that's what had
happened
all along he says things people yell and
scream and then they go home because
that has always happened
the reason people were shocked on
wednesday is because it was shocking it
was a shock what happened
on wednesday that does not mean that
trump's behavior before during and after
was good
it really really was not it does mean
that when you say you know the fair
stories that he incited to mob to sack
the capital and try to kill his vice
president
yes and that is that is fair journalism
right there now the whole goal here is
of course
to create a complete dichotomy between
people who voted for trump thought about
voting for trump voted against democrats
didn't vote at all
right a dichotomy between those people
and the people who stand for goodness
and justice and wonder in the democratic
party now let me just remind you
this could be a moment when joe biden
and the democrats actually put forward a
unity agenda they're not doing that
they're just going to push forward with
their normal agenda
and then they're going to count on the
media and social media to cover
them as though they are doing something
wonderful and unifying and if you
disagree
you're against unity this has been the
pitch all along joe biden would be like
yeah i like unity unity's great also
if you could just do everything i want
i'd make some for some pretty great
humanity
hey that was joe biden's pitch the
entire time so here's the kind of unity
that joe biden wants to pitch for the
country i can
a unifying future is coming here was uh
president-elect biden
talking about his priorities in the
aftermath of covid and making sure the
businesses get back on their feet does
this sound really unifying to you right
here
how does it sound to you our focus will
be on small businesses on main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic hardships
through no
fault of their own our priority will be
black latino asian and native
american-owned small businesses
women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
but we're going to make a concerted
effort to help small businesses in
low-income communities
in big cities small towns rural
communities
that have faced systemic barriers to
relief uh systemic barriers to relief so
there he is
right so this is the unifying agenda
then the democrats will proclaim that
this is unifying in every way
he's literally saying he's going to
discriminate on the basis of race and
giving out government loans and
government handouts
but that's the unifying agenda and don't
worry if the media cover this you know
media like daily wire well the good news
is
they can just proclaim that we are
racist they can proclaim that we are
inciting that we are bad
right they can this is the goal is to
conflate everybody this goes back to the
the punch of nazi days on the left just
a couple of years ago when they were
basically suggesting not only the nazis
ought to be punched which in the united
states if you believe in civil some of
us been against violence the entire time
guys
some of us said that even though there's
nobody on earth who hates nazis more
than i do i'm an orthodox jew
you don't get to punch people based on
perspective in the united states the
left was like no you can punch a nazi
also you're a nazi
right the left five minutes ago was
saying that riots and major cities were
totally fine based on their perspective
do i trust these people to set a honest
good faith standard
as to what constitutes incitement or as
to what constitutes
unity or as to what constitutes the kind
of information that is misinformation or
disinformation
absolutely i do not 100 i do not
okay so that is the goal the goal is to
create again and
exacerbate an overwhelming monolithic
push
from the left in every area of your
culture and if that means deplatforming
if it means silencing
so be it because the left must emerge
victorious
okay that brings us to the update with
regard to impeachment so i'd be remiss
if i did not comment on what is going to
happen this week so nancy pelosi
is now pushing impeachment uh she her
plan is to
bring forward today a
a measure that would essentially
push mike pence to invoke the 25th
amendment it basically says if you don't
invoke the 25th amendment we're going to
invoke
the articles of impeachment now i'm not
sure
if that is even real i mean we're
talking about things that are
constitutional and violate norms
congress trying to force invocation of
the 25th amendment is kind of a weird
one
the 25th amendment is an executive
branch move and the executive branch
generally is tasked not generally it is
tasked in the in the origin anyway
with invoking the 25th amendment saying
the president is incompetent
now obviously the 25th amendment was was
written in the aftermath of the wilson
administration it was an attempt
to prevent people who were literally
incompetent like literally they could
not
sip a glass of water without help from
being president of the united states
it's pretty obvious legally that the
25th amendment does not actually apply
here no matter what you think of trump
incompetent here does not mean bad at
his job and competent means like you are
physically and mentally incapable of
performing
the office i actually don't think trump
has changed very much over the last four
years i think that he's just as erratic
and volatile
as he ever was but i don't think he is
significantly more so except that
when he's disappointed in things then he
becomes worse
but the 25th amendment the push by
democrats to push
the 25th amendment is likely going to
fail
house democrats are saying that pens
should respond to the resolution within
24 hours
and then they're going to bring
impeachment legislation to the floor
the articles of impeachment are going to
accuse trump with quote willfully
inciting violence against the government
of the united states
now that's going to be a very hard legal
case to prove because again incitement
generally requires that somebody be
asking for violence
as i played before the clip of trump i
mean trump literally said peacefully
protest outside the capitol building
because that's probably what he thought
was going to happen it doesn't justify
any other part of what he has done
all along here with the lying and the
prevarication and the pushing of myth
and the
and the characterization of the law but
it's hard to make the case that somebody
is inciting violence when they literally
say i want you to go peacefully protest
and using vague language like go fight
for something which is used all the time
in politics
or we're going to we're going to win the
culture war or we we can't stop fighting
or we need to go over there and make
people feel strong like
that on a legal basis i cannot imagine
that that is going to rise
to the level of crime right you can't
charge a crime on that basis also
it is worth noting that today is january
11th his presidency
his presidency is over on january 20th
okay so really this is more for show
than anything else and you can say that
you like the show you think that the
legislature should should push back
against trump because trump
was attempting to pressure the
legislature to do something
unconstitutional but here's the thing
the legislature didn't do the
unconstitutional thing his own vice
president didn't do it
the legislature didn't do it so when
people say the legislature needs to send
trump a message
they kind of did they certified the
election result in favor of joe biden
and completely rejected trump
and now he is widely derided so he's
going to be leaving
i mean like it's pretty obvious at this
point that this is mainly an attempt
politically
for democrats to uh to essentially
suggest that ever voting for trump by
anybody uh was it was a critical error
that everybody should have foreseen all
of this right it's sort of part and
parcel of the broader democratic
narrative
i understand why some republicans are
saying that they want trump impeached
over what happened
i get it but i just think that it
happens to be bad impeachment policy
and i also think that it happens to be
more politically driven than anything
else that becomes essentially
like even more true when you see the
tactics that they are using right the
tactics that are being used right now
they're not bringing up the impeachment
today they're trying to force pence to
do it
they know by the way that the senate
does not come back into session until
january 19th and it doesn't come back
into session until january 19th unless
there is a
unanimous a unanimous agreement by the
senators to come back into session
before january 19th that ain't gonna
happen
so it really is is not going anywhere
it's mostly for show
it's an expression of outrage i get the
expression of outrage i just don't think
it's gonna be particularly effective
in this particular case james clyburn by
the way says that trump's impeachment
trial
could be held a hundred days in so he's
saying like
it's so urgent to get trump out of
office right this minute that we can
wait a hundred days until after he
hasn't been president
for literally 91 of them for uh well
actually 100 of them right
it's biden's first hundred days not a
hundred days from now we can wait until
he's been out of office for over 100
over three months and then we can have a
trial on impeachment
okay so so obviously this is of highest
highest priority
for james clyburn and the rest of the
democratic party
clyburn said over the weekend that it
would delay joe biden's agenda
to focus in on impeachment right now
again guys if we were two months away
if we were two months away you kind of
see it without the politics but
since we are nine days away uh that's
gonna be a tough one especially because
again they're gonna be criminal
investigations and
into everything that happened and the
story is not probably going to end here
alrighty so we're going to be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content also go check out the matt wall
show to hear more about joe biden's new
discriminatory covered relief plans
watch at 1 30 pm eastern over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavo wydowski our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show
you